[Music]
I'm gonna set the stage for us and I
will say you know whether our users are
enterprise clients or individual
consumers we really want them to have a
great experience right it's kind of the
core of what we're what we're searching
for and I actually had a really
interesting experience this past week
that I think kind of sums up why this is
an important experience for your users
and I'd like to recount that with you so
if I'm moving a little slowly on stage
today it's because I actually had an
emergency abdominal surgery just a few
days ago but the great part is I didn't
have to change my slides at all I just
have a way better story to go with them
so worth it
so exactly a week ago almost to the hour
I started having abdominal pain and I
was like huh okay I want to look up
what's going on why does this hurt and
you know I want to know treatment
options so I type in to search you know
abdominal pain that could kill horses
and you know I see a few different side
options pop up I see I click on one of
the first ones and I get this this did
not delight me I was very frustrated
with this outcome at that point in time
and so I pop out of this out of this
site because I'm like this I can't
handle right now
I turn to the search results when I
click another option I get something
even worse is it loading is it happening
is there's no feedback right and I'm
stuck just really wanting to know why I
feel like I'm gonna explode and I'm not
getting any information so it finally
starts to load thank goodness but the
content that is render on the page isn't
the content that I want what was
happening was you know something that's
normally further down on the page the
way that the code was being shipped was
being rendered first and so I was
actually being shown as risk factors for
abdominal issues instead of treatment
options so I want to know if I need to
go to the emergency room to not die and
instead I'm being told that I'm most
likely given my symptoms
a 60 year old male who lives in a
retirement community not not good but
finally the right content loaded and I
basically told me that yes I do need to
seek medical care and I go to click on
the link it doesn't respond the site's
not interactive yet the main threat is
too busy and so I'm stuck so this whole
experience just no I you never want to
give this for your users this is not
what they want this is the opposite of
what you need them need them to
experience and users notice it and they
hate it but that's a problem that's way
too common on the web and there are a
lot of things that can torpedo your
ability to avoid this and so that's what
I want to talk to you about today I want
to talk about the impetus behind
building a really high quality
experience and the core principles that
define that quality and how you can
effectively measure optimize and monitor
those those core principles so we know
how frustrating it is to have a bad
experience on the web as my experience
just showed but how
Universal is this reality let's put it
in the context of stress response
factors so this is actually a consumer
study done by Ericsson and they asked
consumers to rank stress factors waiting
in line at a retail store right we know
that we hate this and we want our latte
and we want it now ok great
even worse watching a melodramatic TV
show and I stole this joke but it's too
good to pass up Netflix and not chill
then you can be standing at the edge of
a virtual cliff and watching a horror
movie these are all stressful
experiences but what's worse than Kujo
mobile delays on the site great it's the
worst ah well no the only thing that's
worse is solving a math problem we don't
want to make our users do that either
but that I think we all understood
intuitively so I'm standing here because
I want to make sure that all
stakeholders fundamentally understand
the importance of developers spending
time on investing in these core
principles of quality this is not an
exercise of espousing best practices
just for the sake of it it is about your
bottom line
so just to give some more context for
that through an example
Pinterest revamped their mobile web
experience to focus on performance and
saw tremendous results their mobile
website is now their top platform for
sign ups and similarly after
implementing and enforcing a really
aggressive but reasonable performance
budget tinder was able to see more
swipes on the web now than they do on
their mobile app so over and over again
we see the same pattern those who know
how to design and implement a really
high quality experience on the web see
increased satisfaction more time spent
on pages and ultimately higher revenue
so we see that sweet spot is around 2
seconds with conversion rates dropping
with every millisecond of slowdown after
that so it's important to have an
accurate measurement as well which we'll
talk about a bit later performance sites
are profitable sites that's the moral of
this story but where do you start
there's a lot going on you start with a
business goal effectively because that's
what you're looking for you don't want
to just have a great FCP for the sake of
FCP as cool as that is you want to make
sure that you're addressing core
business goals so what are those core
principles that allow you to accomplish
that the example I gave earlier is
actually a really complicated one
because me my trying to actually engage
with web content that wasn't loading
properly caused a slew of user pain
points it wasn't just a single problem
it wasn't just that it wasn't loading
quickly it was that it was loading wrong
and like I said it's difficult to define
quality so let's take a stab at it
there's a lot of ways to break it down
but there are a few core principles that
are fairly canonical and don't often
shift so even in the face of strong you
know new fads so I'd like to go over
those underlying principles the first
step being performance speed and the
user perception of speed is going to be
at the core of our metrics and tooling
discussion in a few minutes but it's one
of the most critical points that you're
gonna want to focus on but there's also
things like accessibility and we want
your site to be accessible for everybody
why would you want to miss out on
potential consumers this means that the
site's content and functionality can be
operated by literally anyone
really altogether too easy to assume
that people engage with content the same
way that we do and while we tend to
Center the discussion of accessibility
on people with physical impairments
often you know we can all relate to
experiences of not using an interface in
a way that isn't particularly helpful
and that isn't accessible for other
reasons
so for instance if you are using a
desktop site on a mobile phone I feel
like I can just stop with the examples
there and everybody can feel the pain or
seeing the message this content is not
available in your area which in India
could not watch anything or been unable
to find a familiar menu item on a tablet
all these things are accessible
accessibility issues as well for
discoverability everything else is kind
of a moot point if people don't find you
right so there are a lot of things that
you can do to help in terms of how you
actually implement your site such as
giving you your site a really strong URL
structure I mean the more structure you
give the more indexable you're gonna be
making your site responsive and that
it's easily consumable on all devices
using rel canonical and roll'
alternative for separate desktop and
mobile sites you know there are a slew
of other tips and tricks to make your
site more discoverable but at the end of
the day we won't the web is all about
driving people to you that's one of the
things we're best at so to leverage it
to the full extent of its ability smart
move
security I mean from authenticating your
users maintaining sessions with them
encrypted communications it's you know
security is kind of a universally
accepted poor quality and it encompasses
so many subtopics but at the end of the
day if you think about it from the
perspective of the end user if they're
not comfortable interfacing with you and
giving you any sort of tangible insight
into their needs you're both gonna
you're both gonna hurt smoothness I
really really like coffee and I yeah I
love coffee but smoothness on a webpage
means that things aren't like Genki or
moving around everything everywhere just
kind of in a weird way it means that
animations aren't stuttering or
unnatural and it also means that
everything just feels
seamless and we all know what that feels
like and it feels good so fundamentally
this comes down to a few core concepts
choosing the right things to animate and
being aware of the performance
trade-offs because sometimes they can be
unexpectedly draconian so watching out
for that is is key using animations to
support interactions and not
unnecessarily hindering the page or the
users interactions so we all remember
Clippy like weed yeah and I said and
avoid animating expensive properties
basically stick to transforms and
opacity changes if all else fails
those are your guiding lights so all of
these core principles amount to being
able to answer this question with a
resounding heck yes because you want to
delight your users and delighting your
users means performant accessible secure
discoverable and smooth sites and it's
interesting to consider the core
principles and how they've evolved in
the context of both native and web
applications many of the web
applications that we've seen develop
over the past few years have been to
enable the same richness of experience
that people have become traditionally
accustomed to in native apps and many of
the web technologies that Thomas is
going to talk about that we've seen
developed over the past few years like I
said are to do this and the strength of
the web has been primarily in reach but
these web technologies have been
changing that equation so yet I already
said this slide I am just like I yeah
I'm gonna keep going
that's one of the reasons why a pwace
came about is to really make that rich
experience achievable in a much more
simple straightforward way so
progressive maps allow your web
experience to be fast because of caching
and prefetching integrated because it
gives you that prime real estate on the
home screen it's reliable with you know
network fluctuations because of service
workers and offline capabilities and
then engagement with push notifications
so it feels very intuitive for the user
to engage with it as they would a native
application and ultimately the slew of
technologies that underpin pwace allow
for easier
treatment of quality as we've talked
about so as we saw before Pinterest
updated their web experience and saw
tremendous results but this was with a
PWA just to kind of follow back on that
context and they ultimately were looking
and analyzed usage for unauthenticated
web mobile web users and they realized
that their old kind of out-of-date
experience only managed to convert 1% of
users into signups logins or native app
installs and the opportunity to improve
this conversion was huge so things like
you know boosting engagement with push
notifications was a big deal for them
and as a result they see time spent up
40% and core engagements up 60% so
what's the takeaway the core principles
foundationally underlie the acquisition
engagement conversion and retention of
your users that's why they're canonical
performance accessibility security
discoverability and smoothness they all
directly impact the business's ability
to execute against its most rudimentary
goals so if these principles are so
important then why do we regress or not
really ever kind of get started with
them before we get into some of the more
nitty-gritty of how we measure these
core principles quantitatively I wanted
to take a look at some of the components
that are less technical that cause
challenges to actually execute against
this high quality experience and one of
the challenges is having all the
stakeholders on board if the they want
to you want to have the organization
fully bought in to the fact that we have
a stake in these core principles and
that it has a direct effect on your
bottom line if there's any disjoint than
that it causes problems so let's take
this as an example I know it's a busy
slide and I apologize but in the red org
structure performance and other core
implementations are siloed from
marketing and other critical business
teams with no visibility you shared
accountability it's kind of difficult
but even when it's shared stakeholders
don't often know who shares the code so
that makes it difficult things are
better in the green or org structure
where the core principles of quality are
well defined they're owned by management
and they're enforced throughout it needs
to be one of the first
things that a team considers when
they're designing something new not
something to be tacked on later I think
most people in the audience probably
understand that pain a little too
acutely because there is nothing more
painful than having to layer on security
or performance onto a fundamentally
insecure non performance site it is it
is painful but this is can be seen in
how organizations often approach the
designing of their web apps performance
is not their thought and a lot of the
core principles come to light in the
heat of an emergency like customers are
complaining we're losing money panic
ensues and then you get band-aid fixes
and as soon as the the fire tamps down
those those things go down in the
priority and that's not sustainable but
like I said at the end of the day these
core principles are about solving
business problems and understanding that
the conversation we need to increase
conversions and we need to lower our FCP
are the same conversation is something
that is so critical to get both business
stakeholders and engineering really
excited about solving these problems now
it's time to get to the good stuff
so we can't improve what we can't
measure right we need to know what we're
measuring and how to measure it
so let's start with a brief history of
things just to whet the appetite again
for why measuring precisely has become
so important so welcome to the human
attention span even in 2000
yeah and that was nine years ago I
realized a few days ago which is
terrifying the average human could only
could have barely waited for the average
page in the Netherlands to load just
couldn't handle it you'd walk away even
a goldfish would be too impatient to
wait for the average amia site to load
and then in 2013 we got even more
impatient and our our attention
decreased to lower than that of a
goldfish humanities great and now here's
the good in the bad news online you
really only have
three seconds before you lose people and
I actually don't know why that's good in
bad news it's just kind of news that
needs to be accounted for so you have
three seconds but there's a lot to do in
three seconds and it's always a
balancing act and you're gonna have to
prioritize the impact on user experience
is critical so I mean you look at the
the fact that the speed it takes to load
a page is the most important factor for
a user far and above how easy it is to
find what they want more important than
the simplicity of using the site and
three times more important than how
attractive the site looks so performance
is important you're gonna be really
bored of hearing me saying that by the
end of this but before we learn where to
measure what are we actually measuring
loading isn't a single moment in time
and there isn't one metric that can
fully capture it so this gets back to my
experience that when a page loads it
begs the question what is performance
it's partly the speed of initial load to
be sure but how do we actually break
that down and focusing on user
performance metrics is a great way to
get started a user perceives if
something is happening am i receiving
content that's is it happening and
that's first paint and first contentful
paint is it useful is what I'm receiving
receiving visible and digestible that's
first meaningful paint and then is it
usable if I click on it will it respond
that's time to interactive taking one
step down so FCP actually measures the
time from navigation so the time when a
browser first renders the first bit of
content on the page so it's an important
milestone for the user because it
provides feedback that something's
actually happening and that the page is
loading the time to interactive metric
measures how long a page takes to
actually become interactive so it means
that interactive defined by a page has
displayed useful content event handlers
are registered and the page responds to
user interactions within 50 milliseconds
so it's it's a difficult metric to
achieve and it's much later in load but
it's important because that that's you
know that rage clicking that's that's
that and this is a great example of a
metric that's great in the
but doesn't work as well in the field
because people actually have to did I
swap that I don't know if I swap that so
yeah time to interactive great in the
lab not so great in the field because
for in the field you need actually
somebody responding and pushing on the
screen to get that get that input
whereas with TTI it's just simulated and
we'll talk about the differences between
lab and field in a minute but fi D is
where we're talking about it measures
the time from when a user first
interacts clicks or taps and when the
browser is actually able to respond to
that interaction so in general input
delay happens because the browser's main
thread is too busy and we're doing
something else and it can't yet respond
to the user we all know that one common
reason that can happen is the browser is
busy parsing a lot of JavaScript we we
know that depending on how you bundle it
it'll affect this experience for the
user and to dive one step deeper than
that on the goldfish slide you lose
people at three seconds but they notice
latency at anything over 100
milliseconds so that's something to keep
in mind we perceive we perceive that
that change and that that measurement is
incredibly important so quick quick
raise of hands who prefers a who prefers
B yeah unfortunately some some sites
optimize content visible visibility at
the expense of interactivity so you have
a it's great it's loaded but you're
clicking on it it's not doing anything
whereas with B you're not seeing
something but as soon as you see
something you click and it works both
kind of suck right like you want some
healthy balance to the best of your
ability you're trying to optimize for
both and that's hard to do so why do we
care about all these metrics because all
of them represent a different part of
the user experience and as we said it's
not a single metric it's really a
cohesive experience so you'll see I know
we have a lot of moving goalposts
sometimes with
metrics but we're constantly trying to
find what is actually representative of
what the users experiencing when
something loads so there are two sides
to the measurement equation as I kind of
alluded to earlier there's performance
in the lab and there's performance in
real world now you can look at this from
the perspective of both metrics as well
as measurement of those metrics so lab
measurement synthetic testing where you
can test code quality the others field
where you're looking at real user
interactions and you know understanding
how they are actually experiencing a
site some metrics are available in both
some one or the other like I said nearly
everything is available in the lab but F
ID is unique because you need that real
user input and TTI and F ID are
interactivity metrics so they're gonna
be sensitive to the main thread'
activity it's good to kind of get a
sense of when when you're gonna get that
rage clicking scenario going on so lab
data is fantastic for a lot of reasons
it gives a sense of how changes are
likely to behave in the real world you
can catch problems before making you
know making things go live they're
helpful for debugging performance issues
reproducible it's great but the
downsides are that they're not going to
really capture a real-world bottlenecks
and they can't correlate against
real-world KPIs so that's that's the
downside so that's where field data
comes in and it complements it
beautifully real world's messy
permutations of devices network
configurations hash conditions I mean
it's impossible to simulate all of these
things in the lab and you need those
real signals so rum that helps a real
user measurement actually helps you
understand what matters most to real
users their actual behavior and that
might be different than your assumptions
best strategy combine the two having
both lab and field metrics is a proxy
for what your users are experiencing and
how they're experiencing the core
principles of your site so we know we
want lab and field data great where do
we get it so the primary three metrics
that we've discussed kind of on an
ongoing basis today are available in
their respective lab and field
environments because FCP can be measured
both the lab and field with users it is
available across the board in tools like
white house
page speed insights chrome user
experience report and it actually as a
web purveyor as well TTI is only
available in the lab so it can be
accessed via lighthouse & PageSpeed
insights and F ID requires the real user
input as we said so you can go to crux
for that my tip of the day just to make
your life easier if you want to get a
snapshot of your labs of your site's lab
and field performance to benchmark
overall quality go run your page through
PageSpeed insights so you can do this
via a web app at the URL shown here or
via the v5 API that we launched in
November of last year at the top of the
psi report you'll see a high level
performance score which is the same that
you see if you run lighthouse and it's
calculated based on the lab metrics that
are measured and weighted metrics that
contribute to this high level score
include things like FCP EFMP speed index
and CPI and you'll clearly see in the
field report in the psi report that
you've run both field and lab which is
really cool to have in one place and
from their respective sources crux and
lighthouse so the two primary field
metrics are pulled out for the URL that
you run and so for each metric you see
the percentage of page loads that in the
real world were slow average or fast
what a tool like lighthouse offers you
is that if you use it via one of the
surfaces other than PSI it gives you a
means to measure more of the core
principles aside from just performance
so you can audit your site for
accessibility best practices search
engine optimization and which criteria
have been filled for a PWA lighthouse
also allows you to dive more deeply into
opportunities for each category making
improving the quality of your site
really actionable and tangible so
setting performance budgets are a
fantastic way to keep from regressing as
well and can be one of the most
effective ways to monitor so we're
talking measuring optimizing and
monitoring this is where the monitoring
comes in budgets can take on many forms
but setting them and enforcing them even
in the context of the latest and
greatest new feature it's great to push
back on features you don't want to
implement by the way
protip it's gonna help your pocketbook
big time so there are a slew of tools
that are at your disposal that can help
you gauge the quality of your site
ranging in level of technicality and I
encourage you to enjoy playing with them
both in the lab and field your users and
your bottom line will thank you for it
and with that I pass it to my amazing
colleague Thomas thank you so much
Elizabeth ah yeah round of applause for
Elizabeth she literally dragged herself
out of the hospital bed to be here in
order to give this talk and if that's
not caring about metrics I don't know
what is so for my part of the talk I
want to share about some of the new
things that we're building in chrome
that fundamentally expand the set of
experiences that are possible to create
on the web and in order to showcase how
impactful some of these improvements and
technological changes can be I want to
first take a step way back and
understand the web as a platform and as
an application platform compared to how
Android iOS and Windows are also these
application platforms and so to really
take a step back I'm going to step way
back to the first-ever web page
published by Tim berners-lee and as you
can see this web page is really just
very slightly formatted text some of
which you could click on to get to other
pages of slightly formatted text and
that's all the web was then a little
something called JavaScript came along
which was famously created and written
in a 10 day hackathon and attend a
hackathon brought JavaScript and brought
interactivity to the web for the first
time ever suddenly you could respond to
user input do dynamic logic on your page
itself and even with this very basic set
of interactivity functionality you saw
the first wave of web applications in
the past things like Outlook and other
native applications have been the only
way to do email and now suddenly you
could just type gmail.com and you were
in an email client where you could send
and receive and manage all your emails
and there were of course many other
applications that followed along things
like MapQuest or eBay things that were
highly interactive and dynamic now
to be delivered directly through the
browser but why were these applications
actually moving to the web in the native
world you can use any language you want
not just JavaScript you have full access
to everything that the computer can do
you can do absolutely anything to your
heart's desire so why were applications
actually moving to the way well it turns
out that there are three fundamental
properties that make the web a really
unique platform the first of these and
one that is unsurprising is link ability
the ability to have a single string that
then maps to the webpage itself and have
that string be clickable from any other
page so that you can find your
application really easily but also
shareable so that I can share a simple
string that shares not only the
application itself but also a specific
document for that application that can
now be instantly accessed the second
property of the web is its ephemerality
and this is a very fancy word that
basically means that the user doesn't
have to worry about installing the
application do they have enough space on
their machine and do they actually trust
the application the application or
website is delivered through the browser
completely sandbox and the user never
has to worry about clicking a link the
same way they should be absolutely
terrified about installing an exe and
lastly the web is the only truly
universal platform meaning that your
application is accessible by anyone on
any device today the web obviously runs
on desktop laptops and mobile phones but
also on watches and I've seen the web
literally running on treadmills and
refrigerators and this means that you
can use your single codebase to power
all of your deployments even to reach
your fridge based users okay so now
hopefully that we all have a better
shared understanding of what the web is
and some of the properties that define
it I want to share about some of the new
technologies that we're building in to
Chrome that developers can use to again
expand the set of things that are
actually possible to do on the web and
the first of these that I want to talk
about is web assembly web assembly is a
new low-level binary format which means
that it's close to the CPU machine code
that your computer understands but with
all of the safety and sandboxing that
you come to expect from the web web
assembly much like
assembly is compiled from other
languages like C++ meaning that you
probably shouldn't be writing web
assembly by hand and less that's your
thing and because the web assembly is a
low-level binary format it offers better
maximized and reliable performance than
JavaScript camps so let's dive in to
some of these advantages of web assembly
in detail as I mentioned web assembly is
compiled ahead of time from something
like C++ and that means that you can do
a lot of optimizations and performance
tuning before the code actually hits the
browser javascript by contrast is sent
as raw source code to the browser and
the browser has to optimize it as it's
actually being executed on the page and
this can cause some of that choppiness
that you sometimes get on webpages
critically web assembly also gives you
more access to your CPU we recently
launched web assembly threads and web
assembly threads let you use the
multiple cores that come on practically
every CPU to fully squeeze out every
ounce of performance and to showcase
some of this performance differences and
to actually hear some of these
differences I'm gonna jump ahead to the
case studies that I'll get to later and
show off one specific example called
sound ation foundation is a fantastic
web application they have a C++ code
base and foundation is a music editing
studio similar to GarageBand that lets
you easily mix and match songs with
various effects they have a C++
application that they compiled to web
assembly and it works really fantastic
but sometimes when you have to render
really complex songs in real time the
performance demands on that application
can be intense they we actually
partnered with them to try and render
one of their difficult to render songs
and we tried to do this on a single
threaded version of their application
and we're gonna get to hear what that
sounds like fair warning this is not
going to be a pleasant experience but if
we have audio which it doesn't sound
like we do so
I'm gonna move past that because clearly
we can all tell that is a terrible
experience not something you want your
users listening to but as soon as they
turned on webassembly threads they were
able to render that same song now
something much more normal and using far
left to CPU so that was just one
performance advantage of web assembly
and letting you really maximize
everything that you can get out of the
CPU another advantage of web assembly is
its portability because you compile web
assembly from other languages like C++
you can port not only your own
applications that you've written in C++
but also the wealth of open source C++
libraries and application that exists
out there in the world and because C++
specifically is supported across
practically every platform including iOS
and Android you can now use C++ as your
common language across all of your
different deployments even if you want
that iOS and Android native application
lastly and potentially most exciting to
many of the developers out there in the
audience is the promise of more
flexibility when writing for the web in
the past javascript was the only option
that you had four full fully browser
supported language and now with web
assembly you get more choice the set of
fully supported languages today are C
C++ and rust but there are many other
languages including Kotlin and dotnet
which are working on adding experimental
support to web assembly and some of
these have actually already shipped that
experimental support the most exciting
thing about web assembly though is that
it is fully launched in all four major
browsers meaning that you can truly use
web assembly to reach every single one
of your web users it's important to know
though at this point that web assembly
is explicitly not a replacement for
JavaScript rather web assembly is meant
to augment all of the things that
JavaScript isn't really designed for
JavaScript aside the dynamic language
useful for scripting if you want to do
simple act interactivity javascript is
and remains the way to do that but if
you want to really maximize your
performance really get that reliability
web assembly gives you that option if
you want to get started with web
assembly the first thing to check out is
I'm scripted Epps Krypton is a highly
advanced tool chain that not only helps
you compile
your c++ into the web assembly format
but it also does a lot of emulation for
example if your application uses OpenGL
rendering calls and scripting will
automatically transfer those OpenGL
calls into WebGL calls so that you can
really easily wholesale port your entire
application using the inscription tool
chain
okay so that was web assembly and now I
want to switch tracks and talk a little
bit about some of the new capabilities
that we're adding to Chrome again going
back to the world's first ever web page
we can see that you really couldn't do
anything outside of the lack of
JavaScript that really wasn't any
additional access or functionality that
you could get out of your web page then
the image tag came along and suddenly
you could show images on your web page
and that was a huge deal and a major
development great but obviously the
story didn't stop there and today many
of you likely know that you can access
location and even get a camera feed you
can take your website into full-screen
mode all these different capabilities
that you've all seen but the picture is
actually so much more complex than most
people imagine today on the web you can
do so much more things like accessing
USB devices sending push messages
managing your credentials reading files
syncing in the background detecting your
device position vibration all of these
different things are accessible through
browser standardized api's but the story
is far from complete and I'm happy to
say that in 2019 and 2020 chrome is
planning to dramatically expand the set
of capabilities that your browser can
access these include things like SMS
verification the ability to see the
contacts that are on a device task
scheduling and even the ability to write
back to files that have been shared with
your website so that you can create a
rich native-like file editor or even an
IDE I want to dive in to a few of these
specific capabilities in more detail the
first of these is offline as you all
know the web is great when you have a
secure reliable connection where as most
of us do on desktop machines but not so
much on mobile the way that a
traditional web server works with the
browser is you go and you fetch your
content you load it into the browser and
yeah you're done but when you have poor
activity or even no connectivity that's
a really negative experience and you end
up seeing what's called what we like to
call the offline asaurus rex or offline
Dino and as much fun as this game edge
which by the way hits pace if any of you
haven't before this isn't really the
content that users are looking for
luckily though in the last few years
we've been launching something called
service worker and what service worker
lets you do is that once you've actually
fest your web application you can
intelligently cache it and then detect
that when the user tries to come back to
your website if they're on poor
connectivity or no connectivity you can
serve that same webpage directly from
the cache and then if the user
eventually enters a better connectivity
state you can then fetch the updated
content and serve that to your users on
return visits another important
capability that we give you access to if
you have a serviceworker
in your application it's the ability to
add your website to the home screen and
this is what we kind of call PW ways and
this is that ability to render a button
that says you know install and when the
user clicks it they'll say yes I want to
add this to my home screen and then you
actually get a standalone icon on the
user's device and when they click that
icon it opens up into a full screen view
with no URL bar at the top whatsoever
and it really feels and looks like a
native application another important
capability is the ability to send push
messages this is something that iOS and
Android has had access to since the
beginning but it's also now something
that you have access to through the
browser and then have that access to for
the last few years it works exactly the
same way it does on iOS and Android and
once the user grants the permission to
be shown push notifications you can send
them directly from your web application
so these together kind of form what we
call progressive web applications or
pwace and these are all about delivering
that native look and feel of em
application using all of the web-based
technologies that are also so powerful
and in the browser and we're at a place
today where you can quite literally
create a PWA and a native app experience
alongside each other completely
undetectable which one is the web
experience and you're welcome to try and
guess which of these two is the native
and which one is the PW
for those of you who guessed the one on
the left there's the PWA you were right
but I'm willing to guess that that was
mostly based on random luck because
these two experiences really are
interchangeable and completely
indistinguishable I'm also happy to say
that with progressive web applications
we've now completely expanded to desktop
it works exactly the same way on desktop
you can render an install button when
the user decides to install you can
simply say yes and then you get again
that same icon in the shelf and as well
as your own standalone window fully
integrated into the operating system
feeling exactly like a native
application we also launched recently
something called trusted web activities
trusted web activities or TWU ways let
you take your PWA and turn it into a
Android native apk that you can list
directly in the Play Store TBWA x'
instead of using web views use something
called chrome custom tabs and this means
that TBWA s share and sink storage with
chrome this means that if a user is
locked into your site on Chrome and they
then go and download your TBWA
from the Android Play Store they'll
automatically be locked in and all of
the data will be synced enabling them to
switch between your in browser
experience and your app experience
completely seamlessly the resulting apk
that you get out on the other end for a
TBWA is also incredibly tiny smaller
than any native application that you
could have made and this has been really
impactful for a lot of our partners in
emerging markets who struggle with
storage space on users devices alright
so those are some of the highlights of
some of the different technologies that
we've been working on over the last few
years and some of the things yet still
to come for the last part of my talk I
want to quickly run through a couple of
different case studies of partners who
have used and adopted some of these new
technologies and some of the results
they found the first of these that I
want to mention is Twitter Twitter
adopted the add to homescreen and PWA
functionality and through that they
found that they were able to completely
reinvigorate their mobile web experience
they see as much as 1 million daily
visits of users who access their
application through that home screen
icon as well it's 75% increase and a 65%
it's a 75% increase in tweets and a 65%
increase in page view slash session
duration which is really powerful for
them and helps unlock more value on the
mobile web another interesting
application that we partnered with more
recently is Spotify Spotify was looking
to solve two fundamental challenges
first of all they wanted to lower the
friction of accessing their application
it's a very high ask to ask your users
to go and download an entire application
just to listen to one song that some
friend of yours sent you a link to they
also wanted to solve storage space
because it's hard for users who don't
know about Spotify the application to
decide it's worth the amount of storage
on their device to actually go and
download the native application Spotify
is approach was to start small and use
rigorous a be testing to detect the
changes in user behavior resulting from
users who were shown the PWA experience
as opposed to being redirected to the
Play Store they found great results with
a 54% increase in day one place
activations a 14% increase in retention
and as much as the 30 percent
reactivation of users who had churned
and previously uninstalled the app next
up is Starbucks Starbucks
similarly was trying to solve two
fundamental challenges first they really
wanted their mobile web experience to
have full UX parity with their native
application and
similar to Spotify they wanted a
solution for users who didn't have
enough storage on their device for the
full native application their approach
was to start with many of the
performance basics that Elizabeth did a
fantastic job of laying out in her
section of the talk focusing on less
code intelligent caching and image
optimizations as well as adopting many
of the PWA engaging in delightful
patterns to add to homescreen and enable
better sign-on and authentication their
results surprised even us and themselves
they found that they were able to double
the amount of the time to interactive
for their webpage as well as a 65%
increase in Starbucks for
registrations which is their most
important conversion point the last case
study that I want to go over is a really
great company that pulls together a lot
of these principles and that's figma
figma is a powerful cloud-based screen
design platform that makes it really
easy for teams to work and collaborate
in sync with native design tools you had
to worry about managing the right files
and making sure that everybody's files
were up-to-date making sure that
everyone had the right software
installed and whether or not the
operating system that's one of your team
members was using even support of the
application in the first place now by
leveraging the powers of links as the
single source of truth you can easily
collaborate ping somebody as you know
single string they can then click to
instantly open up the application jump
right in
collaboratively edit without having to
worry about any of the process of
installing the application itself I want
to briefly mention the actual setup that
figma has because it's quite a well-done
architecture that they were able to come
up with in the surrounding areas of
their application the menus and such
they use a type script and react based
framework which works really well and
then inside of the central editor
section of their application they have a
single canvas tag where they have a
custom rendering engine written in web
assembly through C++ that uses WebGL to
rapidly render that file and any changes
to that canvas area they also have a
custom text editor where they were able
to take the popular open source C++
libraries free tarp type and harf buzz
and compile those to webassembly and
then just use those directly again one
of those portability advantages that I
was talking about earlier
and then lastly they use WebSockets to
enable really fast and smooth
multiplayer editing of any file in the
figma application here are some of the
links to many of the resources that I
talked about I will give everyone in the
audience the seconds to take a picture
or give everyone listening and watching
at home a chance to pause the video this
is just some of the useful links and
resources that you have access to
[Music]